do you think like talking about future
technology and platforms and stuff do
you think VR is going to become a thing
I know the meta is like I know it's cool
to meme on the metaverse and all that
type of stuff I swear we had this
conversation like a few months ago
um I still got this conversation a few
months ago I wonder if
our opinion is full of change yeah okay
so like I think it was my only
experience with VR before was with the
uh valve Index right right and even then
as painless as it is if you've already
got everything set up it's just it's
just a [ __ ] I don't even remember the
last time maybe I don't even remember
last time so I went uh so I visited
City's parents house uh Sydney's
families uh and they had the new Oculus
I think the new Oculus the wireless one
oh yeah yeah yeah it is actually really
[ __ ] good and I don't want to give
Mark Zuckerberg credit but I'm like you
have to sign up for a [ __ ] Facebook
account yeah you do you do I I didn't
want to give my I mean everyone I've
already got a Facebook account but like
the fact that I have to buy this Tech
and then make a Facebook account yeah
yeah
I think it's the one that's like
completely wireless but it's I think as
close as I've experienced VR to be
plug-in and play as possible and we are
playing like a mini golf game it was we
all had our own rooms and it was a lot
of fun and it was like very very casual
as well so I'm like damn maybe this can
actually become a thing maybe Mark
Zuckerberg on the right track I I don't
really know why it's taking them so long
to make a good index I mean like because
the tech feels like the best in the
because I have the index yeah
the index one there's only one Index
right that's the newest one yeah
whatever the one oh yeah I could say we
used to be HTC right yeah yeah because I
used to have that one too yeah yeah I
mean I just wish that it wasn't as
clunky and annoying to set up and like I
think I said this last time until it's
easy and painless to put on and use all
the time it's not gonna seem mainstream
adoption yeah so I imagine that's what
matters spending all their goddamn money
on right now is like yeah please for the
love of God just make a headset that's
[ __ ] easy and that doesn't take room
and isn't [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah because I
think like do you still go in VR chat
and all that kind of stuff uh sometimes
I I just I can't be bothered to like put
the thing on
I'm so lazy I do not want to be I want
gaming I just want to be standing for
like three four hours it's a lot like
you get exhausted yeah you take it off
and your head hurts it's busy yeah God
Humanity's just become so lazy man I am
well I'm good at gaming I like sitting
down dude Wally is just telling the
future remember
straw well my food comes in the straw
remember the days where you had to
physically get up and change the DVD
disc and not just like [ __ ]
Chromecast to change videos I miss DVD
menus I like and they some of them had
games remember the Shrek one had a game
on it no Shrek DVD one had a game yeah I
remember that [ __ ] I had a game some of
them had games and they had character
what happened they actually have games
yeah I think some of them had games yeah
I remember the Shrek one the Shrek one
had the TVs yeah I remember that [ __ ]
and that was fun as [ __ ] oh my God are
you serious yes yes yes let me show you
right now they also had a whole other
animation where they just like sang a
bunch of [ __ ] for like 15 minutes it was
like a whole it was like an OVA of Shrek
did you have did you ever get those DVDs
where you buy the DVDs and you're like
okay I've bought a product yeah and then
the DVD starts and then trailers and
adverts start playing and you can't skip
them or were those just like Blockbuster
ones I think those were the Blockbuster
was like this one you're talking about
like the you can't you wouldn't steal a
TV yeah yeah that that had
[Music]
yeah I remember that [ __ ] oh my God what
the [ __ ] is that what is that see I kind
of missed the DVD screen little bit I
kind of miss it a little bit a little
bit I don't really but yeah you know one
thing I want to [ __ ] the DVD do you
think anyone actually watch commentator
tracks I love commentary tracks
sometimes did you uh um I like him on
YouTube I I used to watch the one when
with the uh Ice Age dvdh the Ice Age why
that one specific because I [ __ ] love
ice age okay and it's like there was
there was a commentary track from the
director and the producer for like 15
minutes yeah and then there was another
clip which my sister and I were [ __ ]
obsessed with and I don't know why it
was this one scene in Ice Age where they
would dubbed in 20 different languages
and they would just keep replaying the
same scene but it was in every single
language and we were and I don't know
why I was [ __ ] obsessed with that
because I'm like haha Russians sound
funny
and yeah I don't know it was just like I
specifically remember Ice Age one
I I [ __ ] went all over that thing I
okay do you have no I was gonna say
that's me in the Death Note laugh I
[ __ ] love the compilation yeah
I remember yeah I was gonna say remember
anime like we used to buy an English dub
with an anime yeah listen to Japanese or
English yeah you still get the the
commentary in for the dub cast or
something in English
I was in that really interesting I mean
I was I was obsessive voice acting so I
always really liked that right and it
was cool getting to hear them talk about
how they decided to do certain things
and that was really fun we don't get
that anymore see I was too young to
comprehend that with my Ice Age DVD I
just wanted to see more Ice Age we just
wanted more content yeah
Ice Age that much I [ __ ] loved ice
age one okay Ice Age one is a good movie
this one's fantastic
um I remember uh [ __ ] so yeah so that's
what I realized the the commentary from
the cast or directors or whatever is
always just best on YouTube because
people cut up actually the good bits
yeah interesting yeah yeah well they
tell the stories that are actually
interesting yeah because I've been I've
been getting it lately with better
Breaking Bad and medical shortages
recommended no because I've been getting
them recommended crazy right where it's
just the the every actor from Breaking
Bad is just talking from the really cool
moments of Breaking Bad and explaining
them and why what happened it's very
interesting and I'm beginning like so
many of these I'm like okay this is
where I like it where I don't have to
watch the whole episode where they're
like they don't say anything and they're
like yeah this was a good bit actually I
remember that's why they actually give a
story yeah and they actually tell you
dude okay sorry tangent Ice Age yeah
right I had the Ice Age game on GameCube
what a piece of [ __ ] that game was my
friend had that what an awful awful
wasn't that the era where like every
movie tie-in was absolutely [ __ ]
awful well this was the end of that yeah
Game Boy Advance was the peak of that
yeah this is where it was starting to
stop right so there were some movies
remember this there was a period where
some movies were still doing it yeah and
other movies didn't realize
so and I remember I had this Ice Age
game on GameCube that [ __ ] sucked
yeah shock it was so bad I was so
disappointed because again that was the
period where I was like I need more ice
age and my friend was like I have the
Ice Age game I'm like give me that [ __ ]
and did you like it no it was horrible I
I was so disappointed I went home and
watched ice age
did you play any movie games that were
good I can think of a million I played
that sucked like I played um do you
remember the movie Over the Hedge yeah I
played that game on PS2 it was a PS2
game for that yeah I hated it oh uh the
one that I thought I I thought I liked
it when I was a kid but then when I
played it again when I was older and I
was like this is immediately [ __ ] was
the Madagascar game on Xbox
I could tell you that was gonna be awful
before you even like yeah because like
when I was little I was like [ __ ] you
know whatever my dad would go to the
bargain being a Target and just be like
oh I found this [ __ ] Madagascar game
I know you kids were watching it before
is it always the DreamWorks it's always
the DreamWorks ones yeah me and my
DreamWorks family yeah me and my sister
were like Yay Madagascar
they know they were [ __ ] because on the
under like the advertisement for the
game yeah you'd be on like on Xbox 360
on the Wii game boy Game Boy Advance
Game Boy Color on PC and um
it was like on literally everything like
yeah and you'd be like what the [ __ ]
that's so bad well it doesn't matter
Madagascar actually no the only one that
I thought was like semi-decent was The
Incredibles game on Xbox I I think I
actually like the incredible it was the
it was guys get all these games because
my dad would go to the bar one dollar
blog
yeah because I was like the reason I've
never played any of these games is
because like I only got like three games
per year so I had to do like extensive
research that's it because like my dad
my dad is not a gamer but the one
console that he [ __ ] loved was Xbox
so we got an Xbox and he played like all
the because he's a [ __ ] Cod bro he
played all of like the racing games so
like burnout and like
Motorsports Grand Prix and stuff like
that so like he would like play a lot of
those games and so he would always go
out and look for more Xbox games and
because we would be playing Xbox games
as well he would just like go to the
[ __ ] one dollar bargain bins and just
like [ __ ] pull out anything and just
buy it and bring it back dude The
Incredibles game was actually good yeah
it was the uh The Undertaker one is that
the uh not the Undertaker yeah yeah
underminer undermine sorry Undertaker's
a wrestler
I never played that one I played the the
original the first one right yeah that
one was good the undermined one was
actually really good because you
actually got to like see the underminer
because he was like because I always
thought I was like because at the end of
the fight in case you've never seen
Incredibles before underminer is this
[ __ ] guy that pops up literally like
lost 30 seconds of the movie yeah yeah
he has like five seconds of screen time
yeah he's just like behold the
underminer and he's just like this
[ __ ] cool character and I and I
always thought as a kid when you watched
Incredibles I was like oh that guy looks
[ __ ] awesome really I just thought
that's a [ __ ] mold no and then my dad
was like I found an underminer game for
incredible like give me that and I
played it was actually pretty good in
the UK we had game and there was they
used to do a thing that was like
three for 12. oh yeah
the three pre-owned games yeah
for 15 pounds so if you really wanted to
get a lot of games yeah instead of the
two main games that you could get for
Christmas yeah your birthday then you
you do that so I did a lot of that
um most of them were really bad yeah
like yeah oh yeah my dad was also
addicted
[ __ ] Leisure Suit Larry games
what the [ __ ] are you serious my Dad
loved leisure suit okay okay imagine
babe station the game
it's literally just about this car it's
it's a really old series but like it's
it's basically about this character
called Larry he's kind of like uh he's
kind of a dweeb but he loves women like
way too much so you're just you're just
this kid who just tries to talk up
chicks in your like college dormitory
and my dad for some reason really liked
these games and I'm like
for some reason I'm like I'm like Dad
they're not even hot bro it makes so
much sense now while you got into hentai
games let's just do Larry was like hence
Larry in like game and I'm like oh my
God that's like naked women it was
always like the highest rated like like
in terms of like the adult rating [ __ ]
it was like the adult rated ones and I'm
just like oh [ __ ] I can't touch that and
then and then I'll see my dad playing
some of them I was like
and you and you [ __ ] and you [ __ ]
judge me for washing hand time
I actually can't believe yeah it was
Motorsports games and Legend Suit Larry
I don't know why yeah the moment I found
FPS games it was over yeah I was of my
addiction I played like I think I think
the first movie Titan game because I
already I think I've already played good
movie Time games I don't know maybe a
good movie [ __ ] off what have you play
Aladdin Aladdin on this oh the Super
Nintendo Super Nintendo okay the best on
Dreamcast though I don't know
I guess what's the Dreamcast
um Spider-Man 2 on GameCube
oh
pretty much yeah I'm trying to think of
other movie Time games you're not going
to put Madagascar on Xbox I did not play
it I was not I was never that big of a
Mad again
I was not that big of a fan of I say
dude I'm trying to think if there's any
anime games that I'm what's what's like
some OG anime games because I wouldn't
have been interested in pathetic movie
Titan games I wanted my anime games I
was a weeb
I'm trying to think because I'm like
what games could I have possibly gotten
oh I guess I guess I just have good
tastes game tonight I don't know what to
say I don't know what to say oh [ __ ]
you're playing genshin right now exactly
exactly anime game through and through
that's that's my bloodline inject it
right into my God I completely forgot
about the Aladdin game on Super Nintendo
that was a really [ __ ] good game that
was so funny I said it was hard as [ __ ]
like yeah
I remember playing bowel toads on the
Super Nintendo oh you know what actually
did you ever play Hercules on PS1 oh yes
oh that was really good as well that was
really good I didn't I didn't have a PS1
but I remember my friends playing
Hercules yes wrong yo that was that was
a really good [ __ ] I think that's
this one right yeah that was that that
was a game yeah that was a game that was
that one that was the most game of all
time that was a game I wonder if it was
a good game because I remember a bit as
a child being really good and I didn't
know if my childhood memory is Warped I
think so it was like a really cool
stylistic game you should probably
replay it because I felt the same way
about Madagascar I said foreign
make a video about the Hercules game
maybe I think so I remember I saw that
video I was like that looks just kind of
[ __ ]
so I don't know yeah what's his rating
what's his rating
nine out of ten oh wow I remember it was
a good game
review uh steam it's not out of tender
no it's on Steam uh and then everywhere
else like 4.5 for oh okay bro I remember
this game was good yeah like I remember
I remember like Disney games I thought
were actually pretty damn good you know
this movie Time games for Disney I think
I actually have the what other good
games today like records I [ __ ] love
look they they weren't [ __ ] Ice Age
okay
what can I say like I like too much
Disney properties I thought Hercules was
one of my favorites even though it's not
really at Disney I think I've ever seen
Hercules even though it's not Disney
it's it's Greek mythology I know about
Hercules just because I see it in
Kingdom Hearts
but I don't think I've ever actually sat
down and watched her Achilles it's a
really good movie it's the the little
devil guys Danny DeVito right yeah I
know that yeah I know that dude that
game is good that game is actually yeah
correct
okay the Toy Story game German playing
The Toy Story game I'd never play this
story what was the game I played though
it was the it was like the PlayStation
game with skateboards and there was Toy
Story in it
yeah it's just it's just Tony Hawk
except he's just in a Woody costume I
swear there was a Toy Story no it was a
Disney
yeah Toy Story 2 and PS1 that was a
[ __ ] good game that was a good game
Disney's extreme skate Adventure
that is not a real game give me show me
proof that that is a real game that does
not sound like a real game this is the
game oh my God my God I played this I
played the [ __ ] out of this bro Tarzan
on Escape what is the weirdest thing
ever I played the demo disc I got for
like a hundred [ __ ] hours it must
have I didn't even know where to buy it
oh my God I want to play that man yeah
[ __ ] Toy Story Toy Story 2 on
Nintendo 64 and Playstation Banger game
because he plays he plays man remember
that first scene in like Toy Story 2
where it's just like buzz Lighty yeah
yeah yeah whereas it's just like Buzz
Lightyear tearing [ __ ] up yeah so it's
basically just a Buzz Lightyear game
it's it's just like that's you basically
get to play that version of Buzz
Lightyear and I'm just like that Banger
game not as good as Disney's Extreme
Adventures extreme skate Adventure okay
with movie Time games are we including
the Star Wars games
I mean you have to well some of the Star
Wars games are all right there's
something yeah what was the one not the
movie Time games though no no all the
independence I mean one of my favorite
games of all time is like Knights of the
Old Republic that's just really really
popular that's just a really really good
[ __ ] game what was that game on the
PS1 that was just like the Jedi game it
literally you just Jedi
the one where it's literally like it's
kind of like a side scroller and it's
Co-op and
[ __ ]
the Lego games are insane as well Lego
games are fun the Lego Star Wars games
for like nutty the trilogy one that
everyone had on PS2 that was certainly
oh my God this is such a if you're not
around our age this is such a like what
are you talking about that's all right
they're related during The Tick Tock
segment
you get one for you one for time for the
Boomers now oh do you know power battles
Star Wars episode one Jedi power battles
that was so actually now that was really
[ __ ] good wait can I see a picture of
this yeah yeah this seems like such a
Conor game you must you must have played
this I saw this but I never yeah that
looks familiar yeah because PS1 games
for me yeah well whatever my brother had
right because I wasn't old enough to
make decisions of anything so it was
whatever my brother had and then I would
oh my God